now when you start making money how do
you monetize like how do you manage your
money give us your money your best money
advice story that's a good i'm the worst
guy with money i'm horrible with
business uh i got a money guy
which is weird because you have to pay
for a money guy but they help you keep
your money it's all very confusing yeah
so i got a money guy and that that
changed everything and then all i heard
was buy property buy property so i saved
up a ton of money like 800k sick and i
just put it right into a tiny apartment
and bought it and it was scary and the
paperwork and the mortgage and blah blah
blah but like if you just zone out all
that extra scary adult stuff
i think you can do it so now i have this
place and i'm trying to sell it to buy a
bigger place and uh that's my plan now
but i'm not good with money i have a
savings account i make like half a cent
every year in interest and i'm doing
crypto i've i've lost a ton of money on
that i lost a ton of money on robin hood
so i'm trying but i'm i'm an idiot i
heard i once heard you say um
you know you bought an apartment in new
york city as an apartment in new york
yeah you bought and uh i'll quote you on
this you said that
uh that's the only thing your parents
are proud of that you've ever done not
all comedy not a tonight show no why are
they so proud that you bought an
apartment i think because it's it's
substantial it's like oh we can wrap our
head around that you know if i go i got
to the comedy seller they're like who
the seller well that doesn't sound great
you're like oh no it's good and so the
apartment is like oh you're an adult
you've grown up a little bit
yeah um what's have you
started to make actual money doing
comedy by the way
a bit okay you know 75 bucks hey
that's a solid there you go um and i
won't say who but somebody has asked me
to ghostwrite for them whoa
that's good money in that yeah so that's
ghost right leveling up yeah uh so what
makes you so bad with money dude
uh i just never thought about it i never
had it growing up and so
i don't know it was just like if i got
money i would just buy beer or buy food
or buy whatever so i never really
learned how to save and all that [ __ ] no
one taught me about money it's where we
teach all this [ __ ] in school about like
pythagorean theorem teach me how to do
my [ __ ] texts yeah what are we doing
here i say that all the time i go we all
go to school we take the most useless
classes algebra biology chemistry i took
[ __ ] wood shop buddy if you don't
know anything about me i ain't cut no
wood that's not happening we get it
you're jewish exactly thank you mark
but they don't teach you nothing about
money no it's kind of ridiculous or
health or just sex just health right
general yeah before the pyramid it was
like eat bread and then you learned
bread's bad for you
yeah
michael sarah so
um so you never learned anything about
money now what is your what would you
say is your best
money habit and your worst
money habit that you have i watched
oprah when i was like 12. i was just on
i was you know eating breakfast and it
was like this guy came this financial
advisor and he was like
let me let me see what you do in a day
you go to starbucks now you buy a five
dollar latte then you take an uber then
you go here then you do this and it was
like all this [ __ ] adds up and i
remember hearing that like yeah and he's
like go buy the oatmeal buy a bag of
coffee buy a coffee maker and all that
kind of kind of blew my mind like yeah
these little purchases
really add up and you don't need to buy
all that [ __ ] and don't go out to eat
every night and don't do delivery every
night blah blah blah so that really
stuck with me those little things add up
and people just got it's five bucks it's
eight bucks that [ __ ] it will kill you i
call it um
death by a thousand bites there you go
there it is you know and uh our buddy
marcelo we brought his name a few times
the guy i'm like he's like i'm like how
much money do you spend on ubereats yeah
so yeah it's like i don't know like 15 i
go that's every day all right so 15
times seven and now we're at 150 bucks
or whatever it's like just go [ __ ]
grocery shop for 100 bucks you're done
for the week because i thought of that
never thought of that bro yeah so and
then on the flip side you don't want to
be the guy saving a bunch but not making
any money so like if you want that uber
eats you got to make enough to where
that doesn't affect you instead of just
saving up i'm going to save up and buy
uber eats i've been saving but no keep
making more money instead of saving
that makes sense
[Music]